i wonder if we might start with mental
health this morning however and you're
announcing some pretty major reforms
to mental health legislation just walk
us through those
well that's right later today in the
house of commons i'll be setting out
the proposals to have a new mental
health act
you know all this this last year we've
been dealing with coronavirus
but also the changes
to the 1983 act which currently governs
how we support people with serious
mental ill health
um that that act needs to change and
we've been doing the work on changing
that and that's published
later today you know the act is it is
very much
out of date it it seriously needs
updating
and i'm really really pleased that
alongside
obviously tackling the immediate
challenges of coronavirus
including of course the mental health
challenges we've been able to do this
work
we'll publish the white paper later and
what it does is it gives people
extra an increased
empowerment over their own lives and how
you're
supported and i hope we'll improve the
uh the dignity with which as a society
we support some of the most vulnerable
people who are
in the mental health crisis and have a
very significant
mental ill health we shouldn't forget of
course that it has been a priority for
this government since 2011
uh to get penalty of esteem between
physical and uh and mental well-being
so hopefully we can we can see some
progress on this but in terms of
those on the front line i mean research
this morning suggesting nearly
half of intensive care staff are
reporting symptoms of
ptsd severe depression anxiety
nhs workers according to this research
suffering more than combat troops
well this is a very significant problem
you know we all think about how
difficult
2020 has been for everyone but for those
who are working on the front line in the
nhs
it's been especially difficult and it's
difficult right now
the pressures of the first peak are now
the pressures of
the number of people over 30 000 people
in hospital with coved
and um and that the increased mortality
rate
put this puts very significant pressure
on our on our teams
on the front line so we we're putting in
extra
uh resources extra money in the here and
now
and the legislation is to be clear for
longer term and
for people with uh significant mental
ill health and
med um uh rather than uh necessarily
those
on the front line but the there's
something that everybody can do now
there's something everybody can do
to help those on the front line and
that's to
stay at home unless you absolutely have
to leave
because that's the best way that we can
control this virus
let's talk then about the very
significant pressures on the health
service at the moment
some are estimating that we could be
seeing as much as 250
000 new covered 19 cases a day
the suggestion from minis the suggestion
from the scientists
from those in the health service i
should say is that the pressure
therefore on the health service
isn't going to start re isn't going to
start easing any time this side of march
on that basis a number of your
colleagues are looking towards the 8th
of march
it's the point at which we will start to
see restrictions
being relaxed that's not going to happen
is it
well it's impossible to know and we'll
keep the
um the restrictions in place not a
moment longer than they're necessary but
we will keep them
in place as long as they're necessary um
on the timings of that you know we're on
track to deliver this
the vaccination program to the most
the four groups who are most vulnerable
to covid by the 15th of
uh february that's really good news the
vaccine rollout program is going really
well
so sorry to interrupt but can i just
just for clarity because there's been a
difference
on this program this week as to the the
target of 14 million
jabs in arms by the middle of february
is that the target
vaccinations the first dose 14 million
of those those 14 million
will have been reached by the middle of
february or is it just as in deemed
highway suggested to me on the program
at the beginning of this week that they
will have been contacted
by the middle of february oh no no it's
that they will have been
everybody in the top four priority
groups will have been
offered to to be vaccinated by
or on the 15th of february that means
that they'll have been offered a slot
to be jabbed where that opportunity to
get the vaccination
is on or uh or before
the 15th of february that's the precise
definition of this
uh target we've made it very clear so
that there's no
uh humming and arring about whether
we've um we've met it or not
um now i i very much hope that the
vast majority of people will take up
those offers as well
and in fact the evidence shows that the
uh that there's
been a quite a sharp increase in the
proportion of people planning to
uh to take the vaccine which is great
but i just want to bring it back to the
opening
point which is the pressure on the nhs
you know
these the measures that we've got in
place that we hope to be able to
uh to lift and we should be able to lift
when we've got
when we've been able to protect through
vaccination uh the those who are
vulnerable right now the vaccine is not
yet in a position to do that we've got
to
support people sorry to interrupt but
you you've just said that we want to
start easing the restrictions once the
14 million have been
uh have have had that although most
vulnerable have had their jab there is a
three week lag
time between the 14th of february and
the first week
and immunity the the kind of the quality
of immunization actually being
taken in so again this this date of
march the 8th
on which we are going to start seeing
the possibility
of restrictions at being ease how can
that
be possible on that time scale
well i haven't put a time scale on it
so it so but i i know you haven't but
some of your colleagues have
well great but i but i'm the health
secretary
that is indeed true that is indeed true
is the words at the bottom of the screen
point out
minister clearly there is huge pressure
on the health service at the moment the
guardian reporting this morning
that we are going to see people released
from hospital early
in significant numbers and put into
hotels is that the case
well there are huge pressures on the nhs
and as you'd expect
we're looking to we're looking to all
different ways that we can relieve
those pressures you'll have seen that
there's now
uh there are now we're now taking
hospitals in the nhs
london nightingale uh that and that is
there as a
as backup but of course of course we
have plans for
in case there's more that's needed now
we'd only ever do that if it was
clinically uh the right thing for
somebody but
in some cases people need set down care
they don't actually need to be in a
hospital bed
we work very closely with the social
care sector to make sure that that
capacity is available but that's um
that's the but we look at all options
and so this isn't a it isn't a concrete
proposal
by any means but it is something that
that we look at because we look at all
contingencies
um two words which i suspect strike fear
into some government ministers these
days marcus rashford he's again
raised concerns about the provision of
free school meals you will have seen the
pictures
and i'm sure your reaction will have
been exactly the same as mine
that if people are being given what has
been shown on social media
to cover children's meals for five days
you know something has gone badly wrong
in the provision hasn't it well yes
clearly and the companies apologized and
and rightly so and you know colleagues
at the department of education have been
uh immediately on this they've met the
company
and the company is uh is sorting the
problem out the
the the food packages that were sent out
were clearly unacceptable
uh and i i'm you know it's one of the
one of the strengths of social media is
that we could find that out
so quickly that was brought to
minister's attention and they
got right on it so uh it's it's a uh
you know it's a problem that is being uh
fixed
uh the companies apologized i think you
know the good thing is that we i'm
really glad that we're able to provide
these uh these meals and this support to
people in what are incredibly difficult
times
so i'm very glad that that's been done
uh this is only one company of many who
are providing these
uh these food packages and um and i'm
i'm glad that ministers in the in the
department have been able to fix the
problem
why is the contract with this individual
company simply not being cancelled
surely there is a break clause they've
clearly not been fulfilling
uh fulfilling the terms of the contract
to which they've signed up so
why are we still using them uh well that
that'll be a um that would be a decision
for the
for the ministers and department for
education um
but i know that the company have
apologized and have said that they're
going to sort it out so
what matters uh is that people get the
food that is that they need to a
standard that they
deserve and i know that people are
working very hard on making that happen